sarah everard's murder was called the
rapist by former colleagues he
had been seen exposing himself his car
was identified
is there going to be an independent
inquiry into how such a person
could come to be
a metropolitan police officer
yes well i agree with you it is deeply
deeply disturbing and i think uh all of
us feel it acutely for two reasons one
of which is
we can we've all walked in that sort of
area we've imagined that happening to
one of our our loved ones and our hearts
go out to sarah everard's
family but also the sort of things that
that you've described the the kind of
warning signals that appear to have been
overlooked i do think it's important as
a first step that crested dick as the
commissioner properly investigates that
and i think we need to just let her get
on with the job of doing that first well
of course the question that's being
asked is
this happened on christmas dick's watch
the procedures that allowed him to
become a met police officer and the
culture
that as far as we can tell appear to
turn a blind eye
uh either developed
or continued
under her aegis is she really the right
person to do that
well you're absolutely right to
highlight all of those concerns and i'm
i'm very worried about them as well as
is the home secretary the home secretary
has made it clear and i think the home
secretary is clearly right in this that
she should allow the met commissioner to
to do the job of trying to sort this out
and find out exactly how this happened
they're a very serious questions to be
answered about the the kind of
oversights that that you've described i
think the best approach is the one
outlined by the home secretary which is
that we we allow the commissioner to do
that but alongside that the government
is taking action so just today we're
announcing 25 million pounds for our
safer streets fund which will help for
example we want cctv and other things to
to help women feel safer i want to come
to that um but
let's assume that chris dick does her
exercise would you
still rule out the idea of an
independent inquiry into these vetting
procedures because this is clearly not
just a problem for the met this is a
problem for
every
constabulary uh well i think it's it's
important that this work is done first
of all by the the commissioner of course
we don't rule anything out but i think
it's it's important for us to understand
exactly what happened and if there are
further questions uh arising from that
then it may be that we need to look at
it further but i think the the first
step is really to get to the bottom it
that's what a crested dick has been
tasked with what that's what she said
she is getting on with with doing i
think it's important that we allow her
to do that if it is the case that
subsequently we need to look at it then
of course we we don't rule that out this
um
this issue
this tragedy has thrown up some
issues
which are wider even than the police now
in your
job as chair of the conceptual party
you're responsible for party discipline
um philip allert who is the conservative
uh crime commissioner for north
yorkshire
told women this week that they needed to
be more streetwise now he's apologized
for that
but shouldn't you have been on the phone
telling him
he had to go the minute you heard that
well the prime minister and i were
outraged by what he said it was
completely unacceptable uh i've been
very clear in condemning it that i know
the prime minister shares that view
he did immediately apologize and i think
that that's appropriate for him to do so
can women in north yorkshire be at least
clear that when you next offer a
candidate for this role to the
electorate it uh the name won't be
philip allert
well it was i'm not going to preempt the
the selection because you're in charge
of candidates uh well we go through a
proper transparent process with that but
i uh be in no doubt at all that the
prime minister and i profoundly
disagreed with what he said it was a
stupid thing to have said and he has
rightly apologized for it
if uh but of course if you lived in
north yorkshire and you had a vote
you wouldn't be casting it for this
gentleman would you
well let's wait for the the selection
process for the for the new pcc okay
let's pass on from that ringing vote of
confidence in mr alex too back to the
central issue um there's a suggestion
that somehow the wayne cousins is a sort
of single bad apple
um
that can't be true can it for example
other officers exchanged messages with
him
which clearly
were part of this pattern of appalling
behavior um
do you think that those people should be
kicked out of the police
well of course
anyone who has
breached police conduct rules should
should face appropriate
disciplinary action i do think though
it's important and i'm sure your viewers
appreciate and i appreciate the vast
majority of police officers do an
incredible amount of hard work keeping
us safe every single day i saw that just
yesterday when i visited gold command
for our conference 1 500 police officers
working day and night to make sure that
that everyone's safe most police
officers are deeply noble and committed
to keeping the public safe it is
important though that of course we
address situations where they rise the
kind of appalling conduct of of this
person and i think that's that's why the
the met commissioner is rightly
investigating it properly you've
mentioned the uh 25 million pounds at
home secretaries committed to projects
that are going to make the streets safer
the examples that have been given are
locked gates to alleyways
better street liking lighting cctv
can you explain to me how any of that
would have prevented the death of sarah
everard
well those are wider measures to to make
sure that uh women feel safe and people
in general feel safe and those those
measures will help people feel safer
clearly
there are questions
none of that would have interfered and
of course what that man did
you're absolutely right
to highlight what i think is an
underlying point about the
the fear that that i have and and others
have that there will be a loss of trust
uh particularly amongst uh younger women
with the uh with the police uh and
crested it has made it clear that
she's got a big job of work to
restore that trust and that that that
goes alongside though the kind of action
in the women and girls strategy and the
safer street strategy which is about um
making sure that people feel safer
generally uh there's no silver bullet to
restoring that the the trust that that
people feel with the the police but i
know that the
the commissioner takes it exceptionally
seriously about how we can rebuild that
trust well well here's one way you could
address this um another former um female
police chief sue fish who ran
nottinghamshire police
has said
recently
that what should be happening is that we
should be treating
the issue of violence against women and
girls
as seriously
as we treat counter-terrorism now we're
sitting a few hundred meters away from
where the manchester arena bombing took
place 22 people lost their lives
the government
partners response to that focused on
reducing the threat through the prevent
programme
which
disrupts
anticipates
diverts people
do we need a prevent
program for male violence against women
and girls
well actually we're taking a a range of
measures to to address violence against
women girls whether that's in relation
to our recent sentencing bill which is
massively toughened up sentencing
whether it's in relation to in my former
brief uh ensuring that uh women and
girls are safe online with massive fines
for social media companies that fail to
deal with this tide of vile misogyny
that we see on on social media so the
government is actually working across
the progress
yes although that that said um vicky
atkins the excellent minister in the
home office is essentially coordinating
all of that on behalf of the home
secretary ensuring that we have a joined
up approach to to doing so and has been
specifically tasked by the prime
minister to do that and that that's the
approach we're taking it it goes across
a range of different government
activities all right let's um talk about
uh the other big issue of this weekend
that's economy cost of living
um
you and your fellow ministers are
telling us there's no shortage of fuel
but the petrol retailers say that the
cues on the four courts are persisting
in some parts of the country
and if anything they're getting worse
it really isn't stabilizing is it well i
think it it depends where you are in the
country so for example around here in
manchester uh i was out and about
yesterday there's the i didn't see any
problems with uh petrol stations you can
get fuel pretty easily here there is
clearly a problem still in uh london and
the southeast and people feel deeply
frustrated and i i share their um their
anger and frustration not not being able
to get access to petrol that's why the
government is working tirelessly to to
resolve that situation and just a
further step we're taking is that from
tomorrow those 200 military personnel
will be
deployed to help drive tankers to ensure
that that we overcome this issue which
uh as as your your viewers know and i
know you appreciate it's not that there
is a lack of yeah petrol is about
getting the petrol to the the the petrol
stations but look this is not just about
about petrol and um if i can give you an
example forgive me if i'm a little
grumpy with you this morning um
we couldn't get
uh
any pastries from our favorite coffee
shop here in manchester this morning and
we're still
they told us they didn't have paper for
the receipts so i'm not going to get my
expenses from sky news we're facing a
series of shortages
and there doesn't seem to be any
consciousness in government
uh about what is really going on in on
the ground we're getting a lot of
reassurance but we're actually not
getting our buns
well i i very much hope you you got your
pastries in the end i think i've got
some spare pastries in my room i can
bring them to you afterwards if you're
still feeling peckish but on the the
more serious underlying point uh about
uh supply chains there are challenges uh
with supply chains we're not unique in
the uk in this for example if you look
uh across poland the u.s other countries
there are there are shortages of drivers
that's to do with a range of factors not
least the fact that testing wasn't
happening during covert you've got an
aging population of drivers but we are
taking steps to address that whether
that is extending the amount of time
before you have to renew your license
whether that is uh beefing up capacity
to do tests we we are we are dealing
with tho those issues but usually but
you can't promise me that there's going
to be turkey there's going to be turkey
on the table at christmas can you we are
may we will make sure that people have
their their turkeys for christmas and i
know that the the environment secretary
george eustis this is absolutely top of
his his list
all right um
you are now in charge of the
electorate uh electoral machine for the
conservatives um
has the prime minister told you to get
ready for an election in 2023 well the
prime minister has told me to make sure
that the conservative party machine is
is ready to go for an election when
whenever it comes but also to make sure
that i as the conservative party
chairman i'm a strong voice for the
conservative party and the conservative
values including in in the media in in
this discussion that we're having now so
we could be asked to vote again in 2023
no that right now we are absolutely
focused on getting on with the job of
making sure that we deliver for the
british people i can assure you that
prime minister chancellor home secretary
they're not speculating about elections
day in day out sleeves are rolled up
they're focused on on delivering well
but you know i'm going to ask you you're
not going to rule out a 2023 election i
it's not my job to call an election uh
but we we know full well that the usual
electoral cycle would take you through
to 2024 but that's that's entirely up to
the prime minister one last thing when
you get there what are you going to be
telling us um
there is a question at the moment about
whether conservatives are truly
conservatives biggest tax rises biggest
tax burden i beg your pardon since the
war no sign of any cuts in taxes um
can you rule out and i know you'll say
this is a chancellor but let me put it
this way would you oliver dowden
be uh
opposed to any further tax rises before
the next election well the conservative
party has always been the party of low
taxes and indeed we've cut taxes
i'll come to that in a second but if you
look at your our record in office since
2010 we massively increased the personal
allowance delivering a huge tax cut to
millions of of working families of
course we had to deal with this covert
crisis and we were we were faced with a
choice uh did we get the resources into
the nhs so it recovers from cobit i
think it was the right thing to do and
did we pay for that properly did we
burden our children and grandchildren
with more borrowing or do we take the
difficult decision up front and i think
that is entirely consistent with a
conservative principle of sound public
money living within your means making
sure we don't pass on burdens to our
children and grandchildren but as soon
as we can
make sure that we keep the tax burden
know and reduce it of course we will do
so